I'm Kelly Slater I've been on the world
surf tour for
uh 30 years now
do you think you retire I'm I'm tired
you know so many contests so much Focus
so much discipline it takes a toll on
you
yeah here we are season two I guess we
weren't that bad
the energy level that I'm feeling
is off the charts you definitely get the
Goosebumps
here we've got the cut after five events
we're cutting the field down to 22 men
and 10 women
if you don't make the cut it's a huge
mark on your career
the cut it's not fair for a lot of
people
here bro She's the Man and he's the guy
to be but this is my time
unbelievable Gabrielle's already had his
world titles time for me to get one
I want to win more than anything this is
pressure like we've never seen it can be
intimidating the fear of people react to
it different I'm dead last if I don't
make it here it's done it's like I'm off
tour
he's not coming here to participate he's
coming here to win Kelly Slater again
Titanic below the cut line she's got an
injury her career is at stake it's time
to put your head down and make a run for
it
you want to perform in the big stage and
this is the biggest stage you can have
this is Sport history
oh my goodness
that was amazing